[Musique]
mon père avait 500 moutons la loma n'a
pris 15 allant néerlandais selon la la
le mans n'a pris qu'un
ans
vous filez encore à l'aise dans six ou
huit films et ce que j'aime bien mon
fils on j'aime bien dire une petite
chanson j'ai l'habitude comme ça c'est
bien rend si vous m'entendez pas chanter
mais pourquoi vous filer la laine
alors que on en trouve dans les
boutiques vincent naturel ça on pense à
sur le bouton vert des coupes c'est gras
garder mes mains c'est naturel c'est
même bon pour la santé ça c'est
d'ailleurs là les une grasse comme ça
ouais
celui qui serait malade dit la même
chose qui me disait quand on avait le
rhume poneys de son maître la ligne bien
grasses sur l'estomac
on était guéri tout de suite vous êtes
ventes d'oxy comment vous est venue à
oui il ya déjà six ans ouais assez comme
j'avais 17 puis l'algérie susciter un
peu moins parce que mon mari relais
m'efforce quoi ah ben il aimait parce
qu'il l'aimait portes gris tour avec les
oncles et pour chanter alors j'ai passé
ma jeunesse
donc j'aime ça et maintenant a fait des
petits j'ai des petits-enfants qui sont
très gentils et leurs familles aussi
on est tous vs comment bien m vous
n'êtes plus heureuse maintenant
waouh quel point comparaison je vois ça
tout cas ravi voilà à tous
tél et à tous pourquoi la wii en grâce à
ses couleurs dans la porte aux orties
tiens ça brime cerner la situation aux
lapize est là enfin ça goûte au plaisir
pas trop jouer ses meilleurs 1er l'on
améliore que l'oim
voilà vous aller trinquer avec moi
ambitieux rapport volontiers d'habitude
on va tous les matins en ce moment pour
le moment pas je n'aime pas beaucoup à
un os j'ai pensé à mesure pour vous
parce que vous êtes un homme moi mais
j'ai jemma plus grands souverains vous
prenez la gutta le soin à la limonade
mais c'est moi je vois d'habitude ça il
est un peu un petit peu plus gros que le
montre on a mangé la limonade et la
goutte
tous les jours c'est la vallée montrait
qu un web social régional cherchez un
jeu vrai petit pas pour finir la journée
surtout bonne journée pour aller coucher
et je vais à peu près juste à la vôtre
l'accès à la grotte vous vous pouvez pas
maintenant mais à votre à toussaint un
autre alors on notera un autre c'est bon
c'est vrai que c'est bon tu avais plus
drôlement bon ça pdci cité ça recommence
oui une reine de bord à la retraite
enfin à la vôtre noté merci
mais bon tout au web
le dock siblot alors la doc ciblant il
alla en amont et voilà encore le journal
vous allez me faisait très mal gratter
ont vraiment beaucoup ce qu'ils m'ont
dit ce sera la mort du village comme le
lieu pour mourir même temps ils font
quoi non plus hein vous quittez souvent
racines village ici pas tous nos jeux
mais mieux chez nous au chaud il est
tricoté va bien comme ça la petite côte
bon à quillan bien malien autobus ont
pratiquement presque ça pue la fille
d'un riche marchand qui l'arrêté tout en
passant lui dit garçon de ville aura
moller depuis londres et tu viens me
ramoner la cheminée
élu retomba voudrais-tu bien y amener ma
cheminée lui ôte on m'a remis
[Musique]